so why do you write why do I write well
you're asking the big questions I write
because I think otherwise I would go
crazy or crazier than I already am it's
a good crazy though yeah it's good crazy
mostly I mean writing is a beautiful and
also masochistic sport that like the
right like I love writing but it's it's
the let's talk about the good stuff the
the create I mean I write because I got
something to say I write because there
are things that I want to see that are
different in the world there's things
there's characters there's people that I
know and love whose stories deserve to
be told
whose aren't told in the mainstream
media or Hollywood or just even the
local press is like whose story is told
how is it told who are the heroes and
heroes who are the villains like I just
don't feel I just I want to complicate
the narrative I want to show a different
perspective and I also want to have some
fun and so for me
writing is the way to be both as serious
or as ridiculous as I am on a given day
and I want to show the breadth of who we
are as people and I want to show you
know there's a quote by one of my my
heroes Bertolt Brecht's old German
socialist playwright and poet and he
said art is not a mirror to hold up to
society but a hammer with which to shape
it and so for me writing filmmaking all
these things are way too not just
provoke people's ideas but to show a
different idea of what's possible and in
this country where we're so isolated or
so individual
we're so divided and put up against each
other and we're all the struggles of you
know American government political
corruption racism go down the list let's
use art to show something different and
not to ignore the pain but to name the
reality of this these are the problems
that are affecting people's daily lives
but what could it look like if it was
something a little different and so art
in writing is about that radical
imagination have you ever written
something whether it's performance or or
a screenplay that it bothered someone
and they were very angry about it and
how about you and how does that make you
feel because now you're feels like I'm
doing my job yeah the the one of the
main criteria one of the main signs of
feedback that I'm doing my job right is
the level of angry emails that I get if
if I'm not pissing someone off I'm not
doing my job as a writer if I'm not
making you if I'm not challenging you if
I'm you know I want my art to afflict
the comfortable and comfort the
afflicted and so if people in power are
you know tapping me on my back if I just
have yes-men as you said just like oh
that's good then
I could just be making commercials for
coca-cola but that's not what I want to
be doing so yeah there are times I'm a
I'm a Jewish writer who writes about
Israel and Palestine I sometimes that
can be a little controversial I'm a
white guy who talks about race and white
privilege yeah that sometimes people
have some feelings about that I work
with a multiracial team of writers in
Oakland even in the writers room we
challenge each other we sometimes we
don't we we're not sure if they're
saying what they want to say am i
speaking on behalf
someone else are you saying what is a
real representation or is that a
stereotype and so the first thing I feel
like is in the writers room is even
before the writers room and my
challenging myself and so if I'm not
challenged or if I'm not surprised or if
I'm not in a new place by the end of the
writing that I was at the start then I
haven't done my own job to myself and so
I feel like that's yeah you gotta gotta
end somewhere new has anyone ever said
can you tone it down and what is your
response to that you know that great
classic movie this is spinal tap
I'll turn it to 11 now we turn it up
wait we don't have time to tone it down
there's too much false politeness
there's too much trying to make everyone
it's not that I want to stir controversy
for the sake of controversy it's not I
don't you know I don't want just to
offend you or upset you for the sake of
of reaction the the idea is can we look
at some new perspectives the idea is no
matter where you stand we all know
there's some things that are you know
white between the rug not wipe wipe
dunder the rug there are some things
that are not talked about that needs to
get talked about and if art and film and
writing isn't the place then where is
the place to do that
you